the Playboy Foundation and I personally
were very much involved in literally
changing the laws related to sex
behavior but also related to abortion
laws we were the amicus curiae in the
Supreme Court decision that gave us Roe
versus Wade and gave women freedom of
choice and that is the side that most
people don't know about and the civil
rights movement did you ever think that
we'd see a black president did you ever
think we'd see a black president I hope
so and I've said we're an Obama was
elected that I would bring pleased that
I lived to see that day come as you'll
see in the Birman film I was very active
in a lot of different ways related to
the racial movement and not only in the
pages of the magazine but also on the
television shows that I did in other
words I put performers on and
spokespeople on both the Playboy's
penthouse in 59 and 60 and also play
after dark in 68 and 69 that were
blacklisted or or not allowed on network
television and whether that had to do
with race or whether it had to do with
political views I tried to base what we
did on on talent have you seen the film
yes yes I have I'm very pleased with it
yeah I've heard that it brought a tear
to your eye is that true
yes that is true more than one tear yes
and what were the moments that that
evokes that emotion I think that they
came at as a matter of fact that's an
interesting question because I had that
conversation with a friend the other day
in terms of you know what was it that
particularly elicited those emotional
responses and I think it had to do with
memories and listener usually by moments
involving the music and just reflecting
on you know where I've been and and
and some sense of real pride in terms of
being on the harder how to recognize
some people that are on the side of the
Angels most the time but I think that
once when I I mean I was just reading
briefly about a lot of the things that
you've affected and and what your
battles have been like against the you
know the religious right and the you
know feminists you know that tell me
about the anti sexual feminist yes
exactly
now tell me what what's been your
biggest battle do you think what's what
was your biggest struggle on those
fronts the biggest the biggest battle
that you had to fight on that well I
don't know when you when you express it
in those terms the biggest battle I'm
not sure I suppose the biggest battle
was the sexual revolution but you know
these yeah I started writing a play an
editorial series in 1962 called the
Playboy philosophy and making a case for
the sexual revolution that actually then
came came to pass in the latter 60s I
certainly take the greatest pride in the
impact that I've had in terms of social
sexual changes but all of that is
interconnected to other things the
changing of the laws the part that we
played in the in the civil rights
movement and and just being on the right
side of a whole lot of controversial
subjects throughout a series of decades
that that changed America